Can you talk more about the resurrection?
This remains a stumbling block for many of your more atheistic followers who
have otherwise embraced you approach to understanding Christianity?
Well,
I can only talk about it symbolically to begin with and that's I think,
not sufficient.
But I hope as I move through the biblical series that I can zero in on that more
and more particularly.
But I mean the idea of the dying and resurrected God is a very old idea
and it's echoed in such things as the imagery say of the Phoenix,
which burns itself up and then restores itself to its,
to its early form.
And I think speaking purely psychologically,
that idea of the dying and resurrected savior is something like a reflection of
the fact that in order to progress psychologically you have to let go,
especially in the face of obstacles.
You have to let go of those things that are impeding your progress that might be
very dear to your heart.
You have to let them go and let them die.
And then you have to let a new part of yourself be born.
So because when you're wrong,
you have to let the part of you,
that's wrong guy.
And then a new part spring to life in some sensor.
It's a new part that's partly a union of your mind and the Union of the
information that's contained in the error that you committed.
And it's like the birth in some sense of the new spirit.
And so you could say that there's this idea that you have to have faith in
Christ because Christ is the way and the truth and the life.
No one comes to the father but through,
but through him.
What that means symbolically as far as I can tell them,
is that you have to embrace the process of voluntary death and rebirth in order
to continue moving forward properly in your life.
And it,
it's also that process of death and rebirth that rejuvenates the father.
And it's also that process of death and rebirth that produces the father to
begin with.
If you think about the father as the symbol of of culture.
So at minimum,
the idea of the resurrected Christ is the idea that you should identify not with
that part of yourself that's stagnant and dad and that already knows but is
prone to error.
You should identify with that part of yourself that's always stretching beyond
what you currently know and has the faith to let go of old certainties so that
new patterns of being can be brought into place.
And so now that's a purely psychological explanation and I think I've made the
case in my biblical lectures that I'm striving for a psychological
interpretation at the moment.
Um,
my experience with the biblical stories is that there are layers of depth in
them that are sufficiently profound,
perhaps because of that staggering hyperlinking of the text and its association
with almost the entire Corpus of Western literature that as you keep digging,
you find more and more.
And so,
um,
I don't know what to make of the more metaphysical claims,
you know,
and,
but I'm going to leave it at that because I don't know.
It's only speculation.
Um,
see,
I guess it is that we don't,
I really don't believe that we understand consciousness and we don't understand
this rule in the cosmos.
It could be that consciousness is just an epithet phenomena of materialist
processes,
but there's a couple of things to me that seems to mitigate against that
explanation.
The first is that we don't have an account of cautiousness that's that's useful.
We have no idea how the material substrate of the brain produces this,
this awareness and self awareness that seems to be crucially important in the
existence of the cosmos in so far as if there's nothing to experience something.
It's very difficult to say in what way that it exists.
You need a viewer and an observer.
Scientists sort of gerrymandered that by positing a hypothetical observer when
they talk about a phenomena where there is no actual observance and so
consciousness could be just an epiphenomenon,
but it could also be something central to the nature of being and certainly
mythological stories presented that way that there's,
there's nature now.
It would be nurture from the scientific perspective and there's the social world
that would be the great father from the mythological perspective.
And,
and that's all there is from a scientific perspective.
But from a mythological perspective,
there's active consciousness and that's associated with the idea of the logos
and the logos seems to be something like if you think about it as consciousness,
it seems to be this thing that encounters the potential of future being and then
determines at least in part how to shape it.
Obviously we're constrained in many ways.
You can't shape things in any old way,
uh,
but we can certainly advance in the direction of our imagination in quite a
staggering and compelling manner.
And then you might say,
well,
is that real?
Is Is,
is the idea that we have a consciousness and that it's free and some in
incomprehensible sense and that it plays a role in constructing the cosmos?
Is that real?
And then I would say,
well it depends on what you mean by real,
but I would also point out that you act as if it's real and that are functional
legal systems,
like the legal systems of the on the West are predicated on the acceptance of
its reality.
And it was an idea that took many,
many thousands of years to to emerge.
You know,
first of all,
the only sovereign was well was the king.
And,
and then the nobles became sovereign and then men became Sawford.
And then with the Christian revolution,
every individual soul became sovereign.
That idea of,
of individual sovereignty and worth is the core presupposition of our legal
system and our cultural systems.
And so we all walk around acting as if every one of us is a divine center of
logos because we give each other the respect of,
of,
of individual citizens who are sovereign and that are equal before the law.
And the funny thing is,
is if someone doesn't treat you that way,
it treats you as if you're free.
Will is an illusion or refuses to regard you as someone who plays a active part
in choosing outcome of their life,
then you get very,
very annoyed.
And so if it's an illusion and perhaps it is,
we don't understand an alternative to it and it's unbelievably,
it's unbelievably functional.
So,
okay,
so back to love.
Well,
um,
it will make the case that a limitation is necessary for being,
and then we can make the case the tragedy is an inevitable consequence of
limitation.
And then we might say,
well,
is being worth the tragedy?
And I think the answer yes to that is love.
And the answer no to that is the opposite of love.
Because when you,
when you love someone,
you love them in spite of,
or even because of their vulnerability,
not that you don't want them to transcend that because you do.
But,
and I think that love is the acceptance of the price of being.
It's,
it's the way you manifest your acceptance of the price of being.
Because if you love someone,
you know they have their vulnerabilities like every human being.
But your basic judgment is that despite the fact that they have these
vulnerabilities that are even fatal,
and that there are certainly tragic,
that it's better that they were then that they weren't.
And that's,
and I think that's the right attitude to have towards being itself.
Uh,
it's,
it's an optimistic attitude and I think it has to be predicated on faith because
I don't think that you can necessarily derive that conclusion by,
by looking at the available evidence.
Dealable evidence has kind of 50,
50,
and in many situations,
but,
but I can tell you if you adopt the other attitude that being is unjustifiable,
then that leads you down a very,
very dark road and then you soon start to work in a way that makes things far
more intolerable then they should be.
So that's,
uh,
that's my answer to that.
Any tips on avoiding booze?
Yeah,
that's a real tough one.
Well,
I would say a couple of things.
Um,
there is a drug,
if you're a binge drinker,
there is a drug called naltrexone that you could consider and you take
naltrexone every day.
It doesn't really have any psychological effect on you,
but if you're a naltrexone responder,
what will happen is that it will dampen your positive response to alcohol.
So some people who are alcoholic,
many of them have a very pronounced opiate,
uh,
an opiate effect from alcohol.
It looks like it's mediated by Beta endorphin and Naltrexone is an opiate
blocker.
And so,
um,
what naltrexone seems to do is dampen the positive response and the positive
response,
which would be opiate.
And then dopaminergic is the same response that makes you want to keep drinking
when you start drinking.
So if you're one of those people that has a drink and then has to have another
one and then it has to have another one,
and you know,
as soon all your money's gone,
then the probability that you have an opiod response is pretty high.
And now trick someone can help with that.
Um,
generally when people take Naltrexone,
they keep drinking,
they try to control,
but they keep drinking and they learn over time that the alcohol doesn't have
the same punch.
It's still pleasant but doesn't have the same overwhelming punched that it did
at one point.
So that would be one suggestion and it's worth trying.
The other is like make a plan.
I would say do the future authoring program,
you know,
because it isn't that you're trying to avoid booze.
Exactly.
It's that you're trying to restructure your whole life,
you know,
because if you're a drinker then all your friends are drinkers and,
and you're used to drinking it every social situation and the places that you go
to socialize or places that you drink and like it's really built in as a whole
set of habits.
And so what you have to do is kind of redesigning your life and you have to
think of things.
You can't just stop drinking.
You have to figure out what you're going to start doing instead of drinking.
There's a hole that you have to fill in and you know,
the future authoring program,
we'll also help you figure out what your life could look like in the absence of
alcohol and what kind of Hell you could end up being if you keep drinking.
And,
and it causes all the problems that it can cause.
And I think you really need to like,
you need to think through the hell that can occur and you have to think through
how your life could be valuable without alcohol calls so that you can be
motivated enough to,
to try to,
to regulate it.
And I would also say if you fail and slip,
don't berate yourself and beat yourself up.
Just start quitting again.
Because you know,
if you could cut your alcohol intake down 75% that's a hell of a lot better than
zero.
And often people go all or nothing just like they do when they're quitting
cigarettes and all.
They all quit for a month and then have a cigarette and they'll say,
oh my God,
now I'm now I've broken the pact.
And then they'll smoke all pack and they'll be smoking again.
You don't have to do that.
You can just decide that you slipped and that you're going to get back on the
wagon again.
And you know,
it can take a long time,
but I do believe that you need it a better vision of life,
right?
You have to find something to do that's better than alcohol.
And that might take some,
some real consideration,
especially if alcohol is a very potent drug for you.
And I would also say don't hesitate to try the nail trek.
Solomon's it's got a pretty decent clinical history and it's basically harmless.
So.